you don't need to be a Supreme Kai to
know how much of an influence the Dragon
Ball Z series has had on the world but
there's a lot more to this franchise
than just fast fights spiky hair and
screaming at the top of your lungs with
over five billion dollars in franchise
sales DBZ is a cornerstone of Japanese
animation and a cultural phenomenon and
the tale of Goku and Friends has had
more twists and turns than snake way
despite its impact DBZ is only one part
of the story the Dragon Ball franchise
has spawned four original series 19
movies over 500 chapters of manga nearly
100 video games and all kinds of
ridiculous memes and debates about power
levels so take a break from your
training take a bite out of a Senzu bean
and take a grand tour with us through
the untold truth of Dragon Ball Z dragon
boy you might think Goku's story began
with Akira Toriyama's first Dragon Ball
manga in a 1984 issue of Weekly Shonen
Jump but his origins start way before
that
Toriyama who'd already won multiple
awards for his hit comedy manga dr.
slump wanted to do something drastically
different for his next project mixing
together sexual humor and early 80s
Jackie Chan esque action comedy Toriyama
made the manga dragon boy which served
as a short prototype to the Dragon Ball
story
a year later Toriyama started a new
Shonen Jump manga series with dragon boy
as its jumping-off point and the rest is
history
literally Journey to the West for
inspiration and turning dragon boy into
the long-running Dragon Ball Toriyama
and his team turned to older folklore in
particular the 16th century novel
Journey to the West the story featured
the inspirations for son Goku the power
pole weapon the flying Nimbus cloud
Bulma who longed the shape-shifting pig
Yamcha the desert bandit the Ox King and
his castle on a fiery hill according to
Toriyama's editor Kazuhiko Torishima
using these details to help hang the
story on was a matter of convenience
as Tony Shima puts it adding elements
from Journey to the West to the dragon
boy story was his idea he says the
biggest reason for that was it was a
free intellectual property as it was
very old in addition when you need to
make a long-running manga series you
need to add a lot more features so when
we moved dragon boy to a long-running
story format that's when the journey to
the west' elements came in the idea of
gathering
seven dragonballs to summon Shenron the
wish-granting eternal dragon was heavily
inspired by the early 1800s novel non so
Satomi hakimddin
also known as the eight dogs chronicles
a condensed story depicted a princess
who gave birth to eight crystal balls
after getting freaky with a dog the
crystal balls then flew into the sky and
scattered across the world just like the
dragon balls do after a wish but became
people instead considering the world of
dragon ball features all kinds of
anthropomorphic animals the inspiration
is pretty clear good thing they left out
most of the gross stuff Goku grows up
when enthusiasm for Dragon Ball began to
dwindle Torishima and Toriyama decided
to drastically change things
putting Goku on a quest to become the
strongest person ever and the series
emphasis shifted from comedy to action
as a result the final arc of Dragon Ball
was the piccolo jr. saga which featured
the most intense fights of the series
Goku was growing up engagement with
Dragon Ball Spike during the
action-filled final saga leaving fans
clamoring for continuation of the story
Torishima later spoke about how they
came up with the title of Dragon Balls
sequel series I went and asked Toriyama
for his input and he answered
immediately by saying Dragon Ball Z
because this is last nothing comes after
this DBZ was meant to be the end for
Goku story multiple times usually with
him passing the torch to another hero
initially the frieza saga was meant to
be the final chapter which shouldn't
surprise anyone who's seen it in that
story the franchise's longest fight goku
beats the strongest most evil character
in the universe and ascends to an
unbeatable form the planet ending saga
was so epic it seemed like a natural
conclusion but there would still be a
long way to go and many more
transformations before the series truly
came to an end
east meets west and vice-versa what does
a franchise do when its creative team
runs out of ideas go to space or travel
through time and DVC did both as the
Super Saiyan success story continued
Toriyama kept introducing more Western
tropes Goku's alien backstory abnormal
strength and alien heritage was inspired
by the lore of Superman
Goku just like Superman originally did
landed on earth as a baby and was raised
like any other human he grew to fight
members of his nearly extinct race
trying to
conquer earth more story turns inspired
by Western media include the outer space
adventure to Namak which was largely
influenced by Star Wars as well as the
following Android saga which took
inspiration from The Terminator movies
Terminator 2 Judgment Day hit theaters
in July 1991 by November of that year
DBZ started a story arc featuring a
badass guy going through time trying to
prevent an apocalyptic future where
cyborgs exterminated humanity it helps
explain why the series became such an
international phenomenon it's influenced
by enduring stories from all over the
world censorship and controversies as
the series entered the North American
market a lot of changes were made in the
translation mostly to make the series
come off as more kid-friendly all
instances of death heaven and hell were
altered Vegeta wasn't killing freezes
men he was simply sending them to the
next dimension the shirts on the ogres
living there reading hell were partially
altered to look like the letters H fil
standing for the home for infinite
losers
mr. Satan's name was changed to Hercule
and scenes of cigarettes blood alcohol
nudity and middle fingers were all
removed changes have continued with
re-airings of the show on different
networks such as when the CW changed up
mr. popo's look to make him look less
like a jarring blackface caricature we
get the idea but it kind of just makes
mr. Popo look like a weirdly racist
genie from Aladdin evolution God battles
resurrection and beyond
after Dragon Ball Z ended in 1996 to--a
animation wanted to continue the series
due to its widespread success as a
result Dragon Ball GT was created by tow
a staff without any input from Toriyama
except for the series name GT kept Goku
story going but it was met with negative
reviews failing to live up to its
predecessor without Toriyama at the helm
save a few specials and movies Dragon
Ball GT s final 1997 episode was the
last time television viewers in Japan
would get to see Goku in the gang for a
long time during this time Dragon Ball Z
was just starting to take off in North
America when the episodes ran out
Dragonball was spun off into the
live-action Dragonball Evolution loosely
based on the original Dragon Ball story
it's
not a great adaptation meet Lord piccolo
you take on anyone to unleash his
vengeance to--a tested the waters for
the franchise's return in 2009 with
Dragon Ball Kai a redubbed whittled down
version of DBZ with updated animation
the success of that series led to a
revival of the franchise with Toriyama
returning for 2013 successful Dragon
Ball Z battle of gods movie in its home
country it was a big deal the movie
opened at the top of the Japanese box
office and made its mark as the first
Japanese film to ever screen in IMAX the
movies critical and commercial success
opened the door for something fans never
expected a whole new series Dragon Ball
super so what's next for the Dragon Ball
franchise only time and Goku's fists of
fury will tell thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]